"The Batman" brings audiences a new, terrifying
version of the Riddler to the screen, while
also offering new twists on old favorites
like the Penguin and Catwoman.
But which characters should show up for the
sequel?
Watch to the end of the video to see if your
pick made the list…
Bruce Wayne's side job as a costumed vigilante
doesn't leave him with much time to run the
massive empire that is Wayne Enterprises.
Instead, Lucius Fox is often depicted handling
those duties as CEO of the company.
In the Batman mythos, Lucius Fox is one of
a few people that knows Batman's secret identity
as Bruce Wayne — knowledge he puts to good
use by helping Batman stay equipped with the
latest and most efficient technology.
Many of the gadgets and hardware that Batman
employs in the field are sourced by Lucius
Fox.
The character received his live-action debut
in Christopher Nolan's trilogy of Batman films,
in which he was portrayed by the legendary
Morgan Freeman.
In "The Batman," it's clear that Bruce has
his operation figured out without Fox, but
he's still rather young and can certainly
use allies in his crusade.
Much of his hardware, while effective, could
use upgrades or replacements.
Introducing Lucius Fox would narratively solve
that issue as Bruce advances in his career
as the Dark Knight.
Batman has enjoyed an enduring and ever-expanding
mythos over the length of his career since
making his debut in 1939, with the writers
and illustrators at DC Comics continually
expanding the character's crew of heroes and
villains.
While the Joker, Riddler, Penguin, and Two-Face
are some of Batman's most popular adversaries,
forging a new path forward for the Dark Knight
might require bringing some prominent yet
previously unused characters into the live-action
arena.
The Court of Owls is a more recent addition
to the list, courtesy of writer Scott Snyder
and artist Greg Capullo.
The shadowy illuminati-like group made its
debut in September of 2011 with the first
issue of "Batman" to hit the shelves after
DC's "New 52" rebrand was launched.
The Court sways the future of Gotham through
its assassins, the Talons — the most formidable
of which is William Cobb.
Immortal due to the use of a mysterious substance
supplied by the court called electrum, William
tests Batman's mettle and even enlightens
him, revealing a sinister history behind the
city he's sworn to protect.
At one point, William is even revealed to
be Dick Grayson's great-grandfather.
Two-Face is one of Batman's most classic foes.
Obsessed with the number two because of his
scarred face and fractured identity, as far
as he's concerned, it's often best to let
the universe decide the answers to life-or-death
questions — with a simple 50/50 chance at
the flip of a coin.
In the comics, cartoons, and in the movies,
he was once Harvey Dent, a district attorney
and an ally to all that was good and just
in Gotham.
After the mob disfigured him, his psyche shattered.
His dark side took root and became one of
the city's most feared gangsters.
Two-Face has appeared in multiple live-action
films.
He was portrayed by Tommy Lee Jones in "Batman
Forever" with a much campier portrayal of
a deeply twisted individual.
Pre-Two-Face era Harvey Dent even made an
appearance in 1989's "Batman," played by Billy
Dee Williams.
"The Dark Knight" entwined Dent's destiny
with that of the Joker's in 2008.
His downfall and rebirth as Two-Face were
all part of the Joker's anarchist plot to
tear the city down.
All along, Two-Face has never had the opportunity
to reign supreme as the sole bad guy in his
own live-action Batman film.
If Matt Reeves took control of his story,
there's no telling what madness this villain
could cook up onscreen.
If the powers that be decide to continue the
noir-style theme for the second adventure
of Pattinson's Batman, Professor Pyg would
have a darkly sinister appeal.
The character was created by writer Grant
Morrison and officially became a member of
Batman's rogues gallery in 2009's Batman & Robin
#1.
Professor Pyg is a mad scientist with schizophrenia
who wears a horrific pig mask.
In his madness, he captures victims who he
mutilates in the name of "perfection."
They are transformed into brainwashed minions
known as Dollotrons.
While he is a conniving mastermind, he transcends
standard criminality in pursuit of his bloody,
twisted vision of society.
Professor Pyg has no superpowers, only his
creepy appearance and skill with overpowering
the mind and forcing his disfigured victims
to do his bidding.
The character's high-functioning Leatherface
vibes may be a bit much for the PG-13 crowd,
though.
Jervis Tetch is yet another mad scientist
— one who recreates himself in the image
of the Mad Hatter from Alice in Wonderland.
He even associates with two rotund thugs known
as Tweedledee and Tweedledum.
Tetch has developed technology that allows
him to control people's minds through manipulation
of brainwaves and a fictional level of neuroscience
we couldn't possibly comprehend.
He often places hats or cards with tiny devices
on the heads of his victims in order to take
control.
Mad Hatter is actually a creation of one of
Batman's co-creators, Bill Finger.
He's even made live-action appearances on
the small screen from time to time including
an appearance in the 1960s "Batman" series
and Fox's pre-Batman "Gotham" series.
Despite his lengthy history, he's not one
of the more well-known figures in Batman's
coterie of supervillains.
He could easily put Pattinson's Batman to
the test, although his sci-fi technology may
be too fantastical for this grounded take
on the character.
While Robin played a key role in the 1960s
"Batman" series, his quirky attitude and catchphrases
only served to add to the comedic campiness
of the show.
Joel Schumacher added the sidekick into his
take on the Dark Knight in "Batman Forever,"
but Schumacher's Batman films doubled down
on the '60s-style camp.
"Holy rusted metal Batman!"
"Huh?"
"The ground, it's all metal.
It's full of holes, you know?
Hole-y!"
"Oh."
A more grounded take on the character of Robin
and how he'd work with Batman in a more real-world
setting would be a fascinating narrative to
dig into.
The idea of Batman putting a young kid on
the frontlines against hardened criminals
is already a difficult pill to swallow.
With the exception of a small reference, Robin
was a character Christopher Nolan basically
ignored in his gritty Dark Knight trilogy.
Matt Reeves could potentially crack the code
and deliver a Robin that's believable as a
crimefighter and engaging to watch onscreen.
One of the more fantastical characters in
the Batman mythos, Clayface might find it
hard to make a home in Matt Reeves' more realistic
take on Batman.
However, like Bane in "The Dark Knight Rises,"
he doesn't have to exactly fit the mold of
his comic book counterpart.
Clayface is a supervillain dreamed up by original
Batman creators Bill Finger and Bob Kane.
There have been multiple versions of the character,
but the original is Basil Karlo, an actor
who prides himself in his craft.
In his most recent origin update, he uses
a chemical makeup that ultimately transforms
him into Clayface, a giant clay monster that
can shapeshift into anything.
He's a fascinating villain that really gained
notoriety in "Batman: The Animated Series."
Bringing the character into the live-action
realm would be difficult and require a lot
of special effects, but it'd be a fresh move
for the latest Batman on the big screen.
Batman has a reputation as a lone wolf, but
he has no shortage of allies.
With Catwoman and Batman going their separate
ways in the final moments of "The Batman,"
there's a void left behind.
Aside from Robin, Batman works closely with
Police Commissioner Jim Gordon in the comics
— and also Jim's daughter Barbara, who eventually
becomes Batgirl before being infamously shot
in the spine and paralyzed by the Joker in
"The Killing Joke."
After her injury, she begins operating as
technical support for Batman under the alias
Oracle.
With the DC Comics refresh in 2011, however,
the character received a surgical procedure
that restored her ability to walk, and she
was Batgirl once again.
Batgirl is already getting her own film in
the DCEU with actor Leslie Grace donning the
cape and cowl.
It's likely, then, that Warner Bros. will
want to avoid mass confusion by also introducing
Batgirl into the world of "The Batman."
However, that doesn't mean we can't see Barbara
Gordon enter the picture and potentially play
the role of Oracle for Pattinson's Batman.
For most of his existence, Mr. Freeze was
a pretty forgettable Batman villain — that
is, until a heart-rending episode of "Batman:
The Animated Series" titled "Heart of Ice"
totally overhauled him into a tragic figure.
Gone was the cheesy obsession with ice that
made him a bit of a joke.
Instead, Victor Fries was given a tragic backstory
and a motive for his villainous ambitions:
His wife was dying.
In an effort to find a cure for her condition,
he cryogenically froze her, but a lab accident
left him imprisoned in his cold suit.
He developed weaponry to match his icy condition
and typically only engaged in criminal behavior
in an effort to further the research to save
his wife.
Arnold Schwarzenegger played the character
in 1997's "Batman & Robin," but it left much
to be desired, reducing Mr. Freeze to a collection
of puns.
"All right everyone!
Chill.
Chill!"
The world of Pattinson's Batman could be the
exact setting needed to offer the character
the emotional depth he deserves.
Besides, sympathetic villains are some of
the most interesting characters to follow.
The brutal mercenary and assassin Slade Wilson
is a fan favorite, whose most famous storylines
involve contracts he takes to kill major superheroes.
Of course, he's tangled with Batman on a number
of occasions.
Video game fans even had the opportunity to
take control of Batman and fight Deathstroke
in "Batman: Arkham Origins."
In the game, the villainous mob boss Black
Mask puts a bounty on Batman's head and Deathstroke
aims to collect.
He's made a few minor appearances in the DCEU,
played by Joe Manganiello — though who knows
if that version will ever return?
Making Batman a target in a "The Batman" sequel
could amp up the narrative's intensity as
the Dark Knight attempts to keep his secret
identity a secret.
A narrative similar to "Arkham Origins" could
be adopted as well, with Deathstroke as one
of multiple assassins seeking a payday.
Whatever the case, Deathstroke would be an
intriguing addition to the world of Pattinson's
Batman.
There's more to Bruce Wayne than a lonely
life avenging his deceased parents.
Even Bruce had friends as a child, including
a kid named Tommy Elliott.
Tommy's father was abusive, and unfortunately,
his mother only enabled his father's behavior.
Tommy became filled with so much hate for
his parents that he attempted to kill them
by cutting the brakes on their car.
He succeeded in killing his father, but Bruce's
own father saved Tommy's mother.
Enraged, Tommy grew up resenting Bruce and
his family.
As an adult, he adopted the identity of Hush
and began a secretive campaign against Bruce.
During the day, he was a successful and brilliant
neurosurgeon as well as a plastic surgeon.
At one point, he replaces his own face with
one that looks just like Bruce Wayne's, so
he can destroy Bruce's legacy.
As Hush, he covers his face with bandages.
He would make a great addition to the live-action
mythos of the Batman.
After all, the Riddler's documentation of
Gotham's legacy of corruption did highlight
Edward Elliott, confirming that the Elliott
family is very much involved in this version
of Gotham.
Just as his name would suggest, Killer Croc
has the appearance and likeness of a vicious
humanoid crocodile.
Because of the mutation that Waylon Jones
was born with, he's been cast out of society.
This has driven him to lead a life of hatred
and cruelty toward others.
In his own madness, he often comes to blows
with Batman during his criminal endeavors.
Croc eventually became a well-known gangster,
frequently inflicting his unique brand of
violence on others.
Because of his condition and subsequent treatment,
he leans into his perceived monstrosity by
mauling and sometimes eating his foes.
While Killer Croc might be a bit of a stretch
for the world Matt Reeves has created, there's
no telling what sort of new character arc
the tortured Waylon Jones could have on camera.
Of course, we've already seen one iteration
of the character in "Suicide Squad."
Killer Croc only acted as muscle and had no
real character depth or growth in that film.
That could all change with a sequel to "The
Batman."
Maybe Batman could dress up as him!
"When Batman came nosin' around, he was gettin'
closer…closer!"
"And?"
"I threw a rock at him!"
Ever since 2008's "The Dark Knight," fans
have been itching to see Batman and the Joker
go toe-to-toe again on the big screen.
Yes, Jared Leto played the Joker in "Suicide
Squad" and "Zack Snyder's Justice League,"
and Joaquin Phoenix landed the role in a solo
film all about the Clown Prince of Crime's
origins — even winning an Oscar for his
trouble.
But neither one of those Jokers directly squared
off with Batman in a full movie.
The Joker is perhaps Batman's most popular
foe, and for good reason.
There are many ways to interpret the character,
and he's often highly unpredictable.
The mystery behind what fuels his madness
naturally creates intrigue.
Truly establishing the character in the world
of "The Batman," would take guts, as it'll
unavoidably draw comparisons to Ledger's incredible
"Dark Knight" performance.
However, it's time that fans see Batman truly
confront his greatest foe on screen again.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.